what's up guys I'm Ted Alexandro happy
to be here at barstool sports you can
check out my new special senior class of
Earth and my podcast is called a little
bit me you can have one thing free for
the rest of your life what do you choose
now you know this is an interesting
question because do you interpret the
word free as free of cost or do you
interpret it as I'm freeing
I am freeing one thing of course of
course
who cares about liberating the oppressed
give me free lattes forever and you
remain in hell you could wipe one group
of people off the earth who would it be
I'm gonna go a step further I think
everybody's gone why should we limit it
to one group let's make it humans that's
the group every we're all God this is
something I asked myself almost every
day would you rather kill 25 kittens in
a row or one dog and I think the
important part of that question is in a
row you're not even taking any breaks
which is the you know that's the
sensible thing to do yeah it's you know
it's gonna probably be one dog if I'm
forced to and I'm gonna pick an elderly
dog who we make eye contact and he's
like could you could you make this
happen so it's more of a it's it's more
of a make-a-wish situation where I'm
murdering a dog who that's his wish what
is one rumor true or false you'd want to
spread about yourself probably that I
murdered a dog but that I put him out of
his misery
you know we had had a conversation he
signed the contract you're in a car
chase with the police what song is
playing in your car that's a good
question actually you know I recently I
recently hit a cop car with my car no
song was playing but I was I was not
feeling good about that what song would
play
what's it what yeah yeah I literally my
wife and I were driving home and there
this this cafe was open later than usual
so I turned my head I was like eh
they're open later than usual and when I
came back I rammed a cop car I do a joke
about it you can find it online the
important thing is what song would I
want playing as the the cop now it says
I'm in a car chase with the police am i
chasing the police are they chasing me
if I'm chasing them I want it to be
something like Van Halen's jump that
really that's the kind of music that I
would want to chase somebody to but if
I'm being chased I would want something
by Whitney Houston if you could party
with one sports team in history who
would it be I would say my fifth-grade
little league baseball team that was a
hell of a crew I don't know what they're
up to now or if they're all alive but
consider this an invitation to get the
band back together
you